today lawmakers will get to work in
Carson City it is the beginning of a new
legislative session with a new political
playing field a republican governor and
a democratic legislature really setting
the stage for a complicated couple
months John langler is up in Carson City
with a preview
so here it is the beginning of 120 days
of legislation 120 days of deal making
of compromises or if you live in Carson
City 120 days of a lot more people what
are you doing girl in the shadow of
Nevada's capital simpler Joys were found
Sunday a snowy walk with the dog pretty
slow mellow so just kind of chill I
guess Izzy mcgoff has lived here more
than 20 years he knows what it's like
when every two years Nevada comes to
town it gets pretty busy it's nice a lot
of the restaurants are a lot more full a
lot of hotels a lot of the
accommodations around here are pretty
packed
it's all for this the legislative
session lawmakers will spend the next
120 days trying to get their agenda
passed or someone else is stopped
however this time Democrats and
Republicans say there are areas of
Common Ground I'm there for good policy
for the state of Nevada not look at the
personalities of it who's who's carrying
the bill or who who wants this bill but
is a good policy this session lawmakers
have the benefit of a projected tax
revenue increase it's the driving force
behind new governor Joe Lombardo's
proposed budget the largest ever 11
billion dollars Democrats wonder where
the money will go education is the top
item on the agenda we're really glad to
see that the Republicans are joining in
on the idea that we have been talking
about and actually passed in 2019 which
is a few percentile funding plan other
key topics increasing State worker
funding Public Safety and election
reform the question is when all this
snow is long gone which bills make the
final legislative cut in Carson City
John langler 8 News Now